i don't know if you're familiar with
ernest becker work and all the
philosophies around there about the fear
of death and
how the fear of our own mortality
awareness of our mortality and his fears
in case of ernest becker uh
is a a significant component
in the psychology in the way we humans
develop
our understanding of the world so
what are your thoughts
in the context of religion or maybe in
the context of
your own mind about the role of death in
life
or fear of death in life and
are you afraid of death
[Laughter]
we cover everything in this every
single topic is covered wow okay
um i so happened to
have benefited perhaps
from living with an older brother who
seemingly had no fear of death while
growing up
and he did everything okay
so he was he climbed mountains he was a
rock climber
he jumped out of airplanes of course he
had to be a green beret
and go into the special forces where
that type of thing
is a requirement right
and so because of that i did a lot of
things outside of my comfort zone
and which probably i shouldn't have done
and hope hope to goodness
my kids don't do them yeah okay
okay so do you so i do i fear death
um i think about death a lot actually um
you may not know this about me
but in my field i was the head
i was the co-chair of the death panel
it's called the death panel
though it's like it's the panel to
think about death in religious studies
um
and i was at for many years so you've
thought about it a bit
a bit let's see i think that people are
a little too confident
i think about life in general that
they're gonna kind of live
all the time and not die i happen to i
mean i hate to say it
i'm super positive and most people would
consider me to be
too happy almost right and so it's odd
then that
i spend a lot of time thinking about
death but i wonder if there's a
connection there
yeah i'm happy to be alive right that's
kind of what the thinking about death
does is it makes you appreciate the days
that you do have
yeah it's it's a weird controversy i i
tend to believe that
the fact that this life ends gives
each day a significant amount of meaning
so i don't know uh it seems like an
important feature of life it's not like
a bug it seems like a feature that it
ends
but it's a strange feature because i
wish it like all the good stuff you wish
it wouldn't end
well you know what's interesting lex and
i do point this out to my students
because we cover
in a lot of the basic studies courses i
teach
we cover all religions or as many as we
can like the major religions
and so take hinduism for example um
now this is an ancient religion okay so
you and i are here talking about how we
enjoy
living in life and things like that well
the goal of hinduism is basically never
to get reincarnated again
it's basically to not live okay and to
get off samsara which is the wheel of
life
and death so escape the whole yeah
exactly
can think of that conditions are so
different that you and i
and my students are happy to be alive
but they're back in the day
you know thousands of years ago when
they wrote when they actually didn't
write it they spoke the vedas which were
the sacred traditions of
india they wanted off they didn't want
to come back
life was terrible that's what people
don't have the
adequate understanding of history that
for the majority of people
life is really hard right and you and i
are
and your audience among the lucky
yeah that we actually life like life we
want to live
most of the time yeah most of the time
you